BRAD PETERSON: Hi, and welcome
to our Workspot session
entitled Low-Latency Cloud
PCs, the Modern Way to Work.
I'm Brad Petersen,
VP of marketing
at Workspot, and with me is our
Workspot CEO, Amitabh Sinha.
Amitabh?
AMITABH SINHA: Hey
Brad, hey everybody.
Very nice to have
you for this session.
BRAD PETERSON: All right,
well you know what?
We're going to jump right in.
We got 25 minutes
ahead of us, and with
that we're going to share this
phenomenal story of delivering
low-latency PCs all
around the world.
And we're going to
combine that with a couple
of really cool demos.
An end-user demo and then
a full-functioning admin
demo to show you how
this is all done.
Let's kick the
presentation off by digging
deep into the title,
Low-Latency Cloud PC.
So Amitabh, what
exactly is a cloud PC?
AMITABH SINHA: That's
a great question, Brad.
A cloud PC is very similar
to your physical PC.
It runs Windows 10, it
runs your applications.
The big difference is, a
cloud PC runs in the cloud,
in the Google Cloud.
You get the same
excellent performance
as your physical PC.
There are key
differences, though.
A cloud PC, you get
data center class
security versus a
physical PC, you're
worried about endpoint security.
A physical PC can take four
to six weeks to provision,
a cloud PC is available
instantly anywhere
in the world.
A physical PC has
a refresh cycle
every three to four
years, a cloud PC
is instantly reconfigurable.
You can change the CPU,
the memory, the storage,
anytime you want.
Our customers are
using cloud PCs
to enable work
from anywhere, they
are enabling secure remote
access from any device,
contractors are using it,
call center employees,
remote software developers,
and a very high performance use
case is 3D collaboration.
So for 3D CAD engineers
in architecture
ending in construction
and manufacturing,
auto manufacturing.
These are very, very
special use cases.
What we had to do for
cloud PCs in order
to deliver this innovation
was to start from scratch
and build a cloud-native
architecture, which
very closely resembles something
that Google has called Anthos.
Anthos is a fantastic
platform for you
to deploy and manage containers
on-prem in multiple clouds
and the edge.
And the port solution
is just like Anthos,
except for Windows 10 cloud PCs.
BRAD PETERSON: Well
Amitabh, that's
a great way to sum that up, the
difference in how we deliver
low-latency cloud
PCs essentially
is because we can do
it all around the world
and put it in the cloud
region next to the user.
So it's low-latency,
it's right next to them.
But also there's that
fundamental architecture
that's massively different,
and I love the fact
that Anthos is so
similar to the Workspot
architecture in that way.
Only for us, of course,
it's Windows 10 desktops.
Historically, this
was not the case.
Historically, what had
happened is legacy systems
were out there with VDI,
Virtual Desktop Infrastructure.
Now with this it
was very different.
The IT organization had
to buy everything upfront
and they were responsible
for building it all
and making it work, and this was
only in one location at a time.
And so the problem is
the end users were never
really happy with
the performance,
because it's like they were
sharing resources all the time.
It might be OK in the
morning, but not so OK
in the afternoon when
everyone came in.
And also if they were far
away from that one location
in the world, they were getting
high latency connections,
and that was super slow.
The IT organization wasn't happy
either with the notion of this
do it yourself
project, because they
had full ownership of everything
and huge upfront costs,
CAPEX costs, and also the
notion of the complexity
and the responsibility
of making it all work.
Now that's kind of bad news, but
you know what the good news is?
You can forget everything you
know about VDI, because that's
not required in this
new world of ours.
Significantly different.
If you are an IT person that has
suffered through this before,
you know what I'm talking about.
And even if you're an end user,
and you've requested a VDI
desktop and it has been
painfully slow and so forth,
you've experienced that.
You also know what
I'm talking about.
Forget that whole world,
everything changes now.
And it changes now because
of the title of this session,
Low-Latency Cloud PC.
Low-latency because the
desktop is in the cloud,
region of the world is close
to the user as possible.
And they're getting
their own resources,
they're not sharing
these things,
they're for them so it's
super fast and wonderful.
And on the IT side
it's a cloud PC,
so you're not responsible for
taking it, buying it, building
it, and then maintaining it.
It's a subscription service.
You subscribe to 100 desktops or
200 desktops or 1,000 desktops
in New York, LA,
London or Singapore,
or wherever you want
around the world.
And even though
it's that simple,
it's also enterprise-class.
It's tied into your
enterprise and your AD
authentication and your Windows
10 images and so on and so on.
It's also massively predictable
in the world of cost
because it's flat-rate pricing.
No matter where you need that
desktop anywhere in the world,
it is the exact
same flat-rate price
across the world, any location,
any user, and any use case.
So that's the amazing part.
What does it look like?
Well, if I'm sitting at my
desk, maybe at home here,
I might have a Chromebook
or a smartphone or a tablet.
And if I install the
Workspot client on there,
I can connect into my
cloud PC in the cloud,
and I will display
all that right there,
and I'm working away.
It feels like it's working right
on the device in front of me,
but it's not, it's actually
running in the cloud.
It's displaying right there.
If I have some sort of
device in the middle that
connects to external
monitors, I can actually
even expand that experience.
So that when I run the
client on the device
and I connect into
Workspot in the cloud,
and then I ask Google Cloud to
provision that cloud PC for me
in the location
near me, like here
I am in the West Coast
of the United States,
I would launch it in US West.
And it would be so
close, I would launch it
and I would have that
whole experience.
And that desktop
would span across all
three of those monitors, a
fully integrated display.
To really understand
the experience here,
what we want to do is
show you a little video.
The video is a recording
of a person sitting down
at a really inexpensive
device connected
to a couple of 40-inch monitors
and connecting into their cloud
PC.
And when you do that,
you can have all sorts
of productivity apps coming up.
You can have browser-based
applications,
Windows-based applications,
you could even
have GPU-accelerated
applications
and still get a
great experience.
In fact, that's one of
the hardest workloads.
And we're going to show
you that in this video,
one of the hardest
workloads out there,
because we can do them
all around the world
from any location.
So let's take a look
at the video now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So that's what the experience
looks and feels like.
You sit down at your
own device, connect it
to your wonderful monitors,
and that whole cloud
PC comes right down to you.
And whatever you had
been working on before
is still there.
You reconnect and you continue
working on your projects
and so forth, and when you're
done, click and disconnect.
And so it's just
unbelievably amazing.
Now what we're going
to do is drill down
into those two words
we started off with,
a low-latency words,
the cloud PC words,
we're going to dive
into low-latency
and go into more detail on
how that's truly the case.
So for this, Amitabh, why
don't you take this section?
AMITABH SINHA: Yeah.
BRAD PETERSON: Low-latency.
AMITABH SINHA: Thanks, Brad.
Low-latency is driven by
a controlled data plane
separation and architecture.
And this is the most
fundamental thing
that one needs to think
about in the cloud PC world.
Low-latency drives excellent
performance for end users.
So let's try to explain to
you how all this happens,
and we start with understanding
first the problems with VDI.
So if you look at how
VDI was deployed before,
this was in an era when most
customers had one data center.
The largest ones might have
two, three data centers.
But because of the cost
complexity of the solutions
stack, you deployed VDI
in a single data center.
And in that single data
center the control plane,
which used to configure
provision and broker
virtual desktops, and
the data plane, which
is the user's
desktops themselves,
were all very tightly integrated
into the same data center.
And so your users could
now be 50, 100, 150, 200,
250 milliseconds away
from that data center.
And the further away they
were from the data center,
the worse the performance was.
That whole industry
spent the last 10 years
trying to optimize and
mitigate the problems
with this low latency
by deploying [? van ?]
acceleration technology
or protocol improvements.
But fundamentally, it's
the speed of light.
It's a law of physics.
You can only do so much with
optimizing the latencies that
are created by VDI.
Now the world is
changing completely.
We're entering an era of
low-latency infrastructure.
So on the left, you start it
off with on-prem data centers
where the latencies
can be low if you're
next to the data centers, but
very high if you're far away.
And most customers had access to
one, maybe two or three regions
in the world.
Today with the public
cloud, with Google Cloud,
every customer has
access to tens and dozens
of regions across the world.
And they're now within 15 to 20
milliseconds of a Google Cloud
region anywhere they
are in the world.
And that's new, that
wasn't possible before.
And going forward it's
going to get even better
from a latency perspective,
because all the public clouds
are working with carriers to
deploy edge and 5G technology
so that this high
compute power is going
to be available in thousands of
regions across the world, where
the user is going
to be within five
milliseconds latency of any of
these infrastructure pieces.
It's not
straightforward to start
with the world on the left and
move to the world on the right
with any piece of software.
And this is not
just VDI software.
When we built databases back in
2005, built app servers or even
SAP, it was all
built the same way.
It was built for a
single data center.
Some vendors might choose
to make copies of it
across the world, but how
many copies are you going
to make for the edge world?
How many copies are you going to
make in the public cloud world?
That's not the
right architecture.
And the folks who
inspired us were
from software-defined
networking,
and software-defined network
had to solve this problem
before anybody else.
And what they implemented
was a new architecture,
which is control data
plane separation.
And we start off with wireless
access points as an example.
Meraki was one of the
early vendors in this space
and they had this
problem to be solved,
because every customer
had multiple buildings
and offices around the world.
Each office could
have multiple floors,
each floor could
have multiple areas,
and you couldn't go around
installing access points
and control planes and data
planes all over the world.
It just doesn't make any sense.
And so they created
a control plane
that was separate from
the data plate, which
is the access point.
And you could deploy the data
planes anywhere you want,
and the control
plane allowed you to,
from a single pane of glass,
to configure all these data
planes all over the world.
Now we took
inspiration from this
and built a very
similar architecture.
But instead of access points,
it's Windows 10 cloud PCs.
And they could be distributed
anywhere in the world.
So our control plane is very
separate from our data plane.
From [? our ?] control
plane, any customer of ours
can deploy Windows 10 cloud
PCs into any Google Cloud
region that exists today
or will ever exist.
And in the future we will also
support all the edge regions.
Now this separation of data
plane and control plane
is very, very important for
cloud PCs for multiple reasons.
So we separated out per
customer, per region.
And this is very important
from first a performance
perspective, because
not every user is
within 50 millisecond latency
of a Google Cloud region.
They are on a local
high speed internet
and they get
fantastic bandwidth,
and so they get
excellent performance.
It's also better from a
scalability perspective,
because we can actually scale
each region independently
for each customer.
It's better from an
availability perspective.
If a region goes down,
only one customer--
the customers in that region
and the users in that region
are affected.
And it's better from a
security perspective,
because we don't commingle
data from multiple customers.
They have separate data planes.
With Google Cloud, another
benefit that we get
is we get the benefits
of all the optimizations
that Google Cloud has done
for YouTube as a workload.
YouTube is a real-time
video workload
that billions of
people are watching
in the world every
day, and optimizations
that Google has made
for that workload
applies very, very closely to
the workload we're delivering.
And so this separation
leads to low latency which
leads to excellent performance.
And so if you talk
to our customers,
the biggest thing they'll talk
about versus the VDI use case
was our customers and our users
love their Workspot cloud PC.
We have customers like
Southland replacing
expensive $10,000 liquid
cool workstations for 3D CAD
workstations with Workspot
cloud workstations.
We have Mead & Hunt, which has
been measuring productivity
of their employees from
home and from office,
and have measured it and
said it's equal, if not
slightly better from home.
And so our users really love
the performance of the cloud PC.
And this is unlike what
I'm sure most of you
have heard from your
VDI users, where
people are unhappy with
the performance of VDI.
Now let's have Brad talk about
how what we have done really
makes life simple for IT.
So you have made
end users happy,
but we've also put in a lot
of effort to make IT happy.
BRAD PETERSON: Exactly.
Thanks, Amitabh.
And with that,
we're going to focus
on the cloud PC side over here.
Again, talk about the fact
that the new architecture
is this SaaS offering, a
subscription offering, where
you just ask for
the desktop that you
want in that part of the world.
And so before we do that, we're
going to go backwards in time
a little bit.
How did this used to be before?
When you take a look
at this, and you look
at this VDI solutions stack--
Virtual Desktop Infrastructure--
again, in this world
here if you've
ever done this, you
pick a location in
the world and you
purchase all sorts of
software and hardware,
and a truck comes and dumps
it all on your driveway.
And you pull it all
into your data center,
and you have to build
all this from scratch.
You pay for the
whole thing upfront.
It's all your risk.
And think about this,
you've got to build it out.
So you've got CPU,
network, memory, storage,
all this utilization go
ins to-- their capacity
is set to support a certain
number of virtual desktops
and so forth.
And then you've got to put a
brokering system on that so you
can get your users to come in
and connect to the right space,
but then you have all
sorts of integration
you have to do into maybe
authentication or back end
systems.
And then you've got
various layers of support.
You got support layers just to
support the stack you built,
and then other support layers to
actually support the end users
and so forth.
So you got it, right?
So it's complicated, expensive,
and you are completely
on the hook, and that was just
one location in the world.
So how does that contrast
with this new architecture
from Workspot?
The idea now is you don't
buy any of that up front,
and you don't build
any of that ever,
and you don't support it either.
When you actually
want a desktop that's
configured with a certain
number of GPU memory
and storage and a
location of the world,
you sort of click
that, push that button,
and it is provisioned.
And that person can
come in in minutes
and consume that
and start working.
In fact, in the upcoming demo,
we're going to show you that.
We're going to launch
thousands of new desktops
in multiple regions around the
world in this demonstration
right here in the
next few minutes,
and it's only going to take a
few minutes to actually show
you that.
And so this is the idea,
with this new architecture,
effectively, it's a
subscription service.
You will have Level
1 Support, and you'll
have desktop maintenance because
it's your Windows 10 image
and you'll help your users.
But other than that,
underneath that,
it's a service from Workspot.
So let's drill into
that a little more.
If you take a look at the
slide here, what's going on?
We got the Workspot
cloud on top.
And those dotted
lines coming down,
those are the control
signals that Amitabh
was talking about a minute ago.
Now underneath that, this is the
punchline of everything today,
it's the end user on the
left and their Windows 10
desktop on the right.
And you would want to
make it so that they
can connect into that
thing quickly and have
a great experience, that's
what it's all about.
Well there's three
things in between there.
We connect into
our Workspot client
that they run on their
device, the end user does.
And when they fire
off the client,
it makes a connection
into the cloud
and connects to the gateway for
encryption and authentication
and various things.
And then it connects
to our agent that
runs on their Windows 10
desktop up in the cloud,
there's those three things.
So our cloud is configuring
those with the dotted lines.
And then of course, while
those things are running
they're reporting back,
making sure things
are humming along famously.
And so effectively,
it's that simple.
It's simple to operate
and deploy and sort
of work with this
environment here,
and we want to keep
it that simple.
But realize this, that there's
more going on under the hood.
So the IT organization is going
to see this happening below,
and you can monitor
all this as well.
On the client side, of
course the Workspot client
is running on an
endpoint of their choice.
Could be a laptop or
a Mac, or it could
be a smartphone or tablet.
It's going to have
various networks
like wireless networks, or
wired networks, or cellular.
It's going to come
into the cloud,
then from the cloud it's going
to pick a region of the world,
and of course it's going to
have a particular gateway
with a version.
And now once it's in
there, it's actually
going to connect into
the Workspot agent that's
running on their desktop,
on their Windows 10 desktop.
And there's going to be a
specific configuration of CPU,
and storage, and memory to allow
them to run their applications.
And connect it into a super
high-speed network in the cloud
so they can connect
into their files,
their back-end
application servers,
maybe to their
corporate data center
as well as into the internet.
So all of this is happening.
The IT Organization.
Can monitor all
this activity, you
see all the dotted
lines, all of that
is configuring it and
then reporting back
to make certain everything's
humming away famously.
And then the solid blue line
through the middle, that's
the end user, the data path.
The data path is
quickly to the desktop,
and then the desktop
pings back to the user
to make sure this is
happening everywhere.
Now the architecture
is obviously
set up to be smooth
and simple to operate
at this level with one
person, but guess what?
The architecture
is actually built
to support thousands and
thousands and thousands
of users around the world.
We actually have the
Workspot support organization
running our Network
Operations Center, our NOC.
And our NOC monitors
all this activity
from all the customers
and all the users
wherever they are in the world.
And it does this so it can
find patterns out there.
Patterns so we can be
proactive about making certain
that priority one
happens, which is
that all those users on the
left have a great experience.
And if there's any trend that
comes out of these patterns,
like an operating
system that's acting up,
or a device type, or a
gateway, or a region,
one of those things
might set off an alarm.
And we can take that information
and we can share that
with that customer,
but other customers
that it might affect also.
This is single pane of
glass, a NOC for our support
organization to tell
all this information.
Now we have this great demo
that I talked about earlier,
where it's going to be launching
thousands of cloud desktops
across multiple
regions, and you're
going to see a
demonstration of the NOC
monitoring all this
capability also.
Now there's a lot going on
here, but again, don't worry.
It's simple to deploy,
scale, and operate.
This is the world typically
the IT organization sees.
They want 10, 100, 1000
desktops in the region.
They click a button,
and away they go.
And you'll see
that the demo too.
Even though it's simple,
it's still enterprise-class.
It's totally enterprise-class
because it's your Windows 10
image, it's your
corporate applications
and antivirus installed in it,
you use your AD authentication
and multi-factor authentication,
and your group security
policies and so
forth drive control
of access and the abilities
that people either have
or don't have.
And then for image
management tools,
you can use what
you're doing now,
because these VMs
in the cloud are
very similar to standard VMs.
Using your tools to
manage them is just
like managing physical PCs.
So with that, what
we're going to do
now is we're going to
go and see that demo.
So what we have for the
demo is a fictitious company
called World Co.
So this is a global company,
employees around the world,
and they have come to
us with the requirement
of being multi-cloud and
multi-region and even hybrid.
And so we've got
Windows 10 desktops.
cloud PCs, in different
clouds around the world
and different regions and
even on-prem and on edge,
so it's like everywhere.
But it's still all managed
from single pane of glass.
And then the request
comes in that there's
a merger and an
acquisition happening,
and we need to launch
thousands of cloud PCs
in multiple regions.
And so you're going to see that.
Now when that
happens, we can go in
and take a look at the
real-time security event feed.
So imagine World Co's
IT administrators
launching all this and
then looking at activity
of users that are out there.
But then we go behind the scenes
where the Workspot customer
support organization uses
the Network Operations
Center, the NOC, to
monitor all of the activity
like I said before.
To take a look at
those trends, to share
the insight and the greater
good across all customers,
all users, wherever
they are in the world.
So without further ado, let's
go ahead and take a look
at that demonstration.
Here we go.
Our fictitious
company, World Co,
has a multi-cloud setup
across GCP and Azure.
They also have an
edge set up in Dallas.
Across these clouds
and edge, they
have Cloud PC
resource pools set up
in 10 different regions
around the world.
We've got three GPU regions and
three desktop regions in Google
Cloud, three desktop
regions in Azure,
and an edge
development in Dallas.
All of this is already setup
as they're using it today.
And as it Workspot admin,
it's easy to manage this
from a single pane of glass.
Now World Co has just
acquired a company
with users on the
East and West Coast,
and IT gets a request to add
thousands of new cloud PCs
on each coast.
I'm going to increase
the total cloud
PCs of each of these east and
west resource pools to 1,000,
and it's only going to
take three to four minutes
to provision all of these.
That's crazy.
Now we'll increase the number
of cloud PCs in the west.
And as we do, the CPU storage
and networking resources
and Google Cloud, East
and West, are dynamically
assembled to create the new
cloud PCs and configure them
and ready them for their
users in the regions closest
to their location.
Excellent.
While that's happening, let's
look at the events feed.
The events feed captures
end user activity
in near real time,
users connecting
from different parts of the
world from different devices.
And depending on
your requirements,
we have even more
user activity that
can be captured and fed into
Splunk and other SIM monitoring
apps.
As an admin in the system
you can see my event trail.
There are my actions
adding thousands
of desktops in two different
parts of the world.
For all of these
new cloud PCs I just
got a request to give them
the ability to print locally.
So let's make a
security change enabling
printing for the whole group.
Scroll down here, find
the actual attribute,
enable printing.
Scroll to the bottom and hit
Save and then bang, that's it.
When the users log in next time,
the new policy will be pushed,
and printing will be
enabled for each of them.
Now I'll open up
my Workspot client
running on my local machine.
As an admin, I've
given myself access
to all the GPU-accelerated
workstations and desktops
in all 10 pools.
As soon as I logged
in I automatically
received the new
security policy,
and now I have the printing
enabled on all my desktops.
Let's connect to my Windows
10 desktop in Google Cloud US
West.
That's closest to
me, and I'm going
to show you how fast it is.
Takes only five to seven seconds
to connect to the desktop.
I can move this window
around, this is my cloud PC.
And if I click I go full screen,
I can show all of my work.
So I've got a browser
open here where
I'm looking at
workspot.com website.
And in another tab, I've
got Workspot's YouTube page
full of lots of cool
customer success videos
and a whole lot more.
Also down below, open up
a couple of PDF files,
we've got Southland
Industries case studies
and viewing an interesting
analyst report.
I can also manage
my files from here
and share them with others.
I can open up
office applications
like PowerPoint and Word and
just go ahead and edit away.
I can run all sorts of
browser-based or Windows
10-based applications that it
might even be GPU accelerated
if I need it.
So if I shrink this down--
remind you that this
is my cloud PC--
I can go anywhere and
disconnect, close the client,
and it's waiting for
me there when I return.
Before we check on the progress
of the thousands of desktops
we created a few
minutes ago, I'm
going to show you the Workspot
Network Operations Center
that our support team
is using to monitor
in real time what is going on
for all users in the world.
As we scroll you'll see
the yellows are warnings,
greens are good, and
reds are problems.
We're collecting
a few dozen pieces
of information in real
time for each user
and for all of our customers
everywhere in the world.
We analyzed the data
across all of our customers
to understand if there are
significant patterns disrupting
user access.
Could be an office
network making
access slow for all
users at one customer,
or maybe an operating system
update causing problems
for all users on a
particular device, or even
a region of the cloud being
unavailable to all customers
in that part of the world.
Now we'll look at a
visual representation
by pushing on the map button.
In there, I can see all
the regions World Co is
deployed all around the world.
And if I mouse
over those regions,
I can see the number of
users deployed there.
1,005 in the west
and the east, which
is 1,000 desktops and
five GPU workstations.
Let's go take a
look at the users.
Where are the users?
Visually I can see
where they're located
and how many there are
in different locations
of the world.
We can also look at alarms.
For any reason, if a user
cannot connect from anywhere,
you'll see an alarm.
Is it one user or more users?
We have the visibility
across all of our customers.
If a region of the
cloud goes down,
we can see that across
all customers affected.
Only Workspot has
that visibility,
and it helps isolate the
actual cause of the problem.
So there you go.
Creating thousands
of new cloud PCs
in multiple regions
for users anywhere
in the world in minutes.
As we scroll down through
the eastern region
we can see all those new cloud
PCs fully provisioned, fully
qualified domain names and ready
to go for each of the users.
We can also go into the west
and scroll down and show
all of those
additional cloud PCs
ready for the users
in the western region.
Ready for them to log in,
provision their desktop,
and go to work.
That's how it Workspot is simple
to deploy, scale, and operate.
Well I'd really like to
thank everyone for joining us
today for the Workspot session.
Low-latency cloud PCs,
the modern way to work.
I hope the presentation
and the demonstrations
were very useful for your
teams to figure the best
way to bring cloud PCs
into your organizations
and increase productivity.
If you have any more
questions there's
a little information on
the screen for you there.
Go to workspot.com/GCP,
additional information beyond
the presentation today.
And if you want
to reach out, just
reach out to
sales@workspot.com and we
will get right back to you.
Amitabh, any final thoughts?
AMITABH SINHA:
Thank you everybody
for attending the session.
Thank you to Google.
We are working very
collaboratively
with multiple Google teams.
Of course the Google Cloud
team, Google Maps team,
Google Chromebook team,
Ads, Google Ads team.
And thank you to
Google for inviting
us to present at this session.
Thank you everybody.